Yeah.
Noncommunicable diseases are the
diseases that you and I are most
familiar with.
There are things like diabetes and heart
disease and unfortunately I think that
if you run your hand over the planet,
you'll see that in the poorest countries
there's extremely little that's being
done across these dimensions.
These diseases are not getting the
attention that they deserve and yet they
are becoming a larger and larger piece
of the puzzle of public health.
So in Rwanda and Kenya and Ethiopia and
a number of countries where I've worked
over the years,
we've seen large numbers of new type one
and type two diabetes coming through the
door.
Just a couple months ago,
I was out at a health center where a man
who was suffering with type one diabetes
was actually living at the health center
because he didn't have the authority to
provide himself with daily injections of
insulin.
Of course,
this would never happen in the u s or in
a rich country.
He'd get his needles and he'd get his
insulin and he'd be able to inject
himself at home.
But where there is care that's given,
it's given without very much instruction
or very much knowledge of these
diseases.
One of the perhaps best interventions
that we can make as a world today in the
area of public health is around these
noncommunicable diseases.
We've actually got to start taking a
look at heart disease and poor
countries.
I know that in China for example,
heart disease has become one of the top
killers in Rwanda,
in sub Saharan Africa.
Uh,
heart disease is a major killer,
but it's a bit of a silent killer
because people haven't attracted over
the years it hasn't been as interesting,
nor has it attracted as much donor
dollars as something like aids,
tuberculosis or malaria.
And yet it's still claiming a huge
number of lives and a lot of
productivity.
Even though we don't have the best of
baseline data,
we do know that the impact is enormous,
and we know that with changing diets and
poor countries with urbanization,
with increase in smoking and basically
bad rich country habits,
people are going to be getting sicker
and sicker earlier and earlier,
and now is the time to really prevent
this disease,
which is going to be the next wave of
pandemic that hits the way
[inaudible].